أقول لكم ما هو الخير الذي سلبوا حياتي
لقد أخذوا قلبي
أخذوا طفلي بعيدًا
ماذا تريدني ان
يقولون أنه يقتلك سيقتلون طفلي
افتقده
لا تريد أن تعرف كيف تعرف
انها الألم
لا يمكنني التحمل بعد الآن ، أحتاج إلى رؤية ما لدي
بني أحبه
صباح امس قال مرحبا احبك
خرجنا في نفس الوقت الذي نزيله فيه
تركت سأعطي 20 يورو
أنه يذهب لتناول الطعام في مطعم McDo ليأخذ ما لديه
الإفطار غادرت للعمل
للأسف بعد ساعة لدي
اتصل ليخبرني أن شخصًا ما أطلق النار على
نجل كل صباح كل ليلة
مساء الخير يا أمي صباح الخير يا أمي أحبك
أمي كان لي الحق في ذلك كل
أيام كل يوم عيد الميلاد كان ابني
صبي يبلغ من العمر 17 عاما محترما
عطوف
حب
مفيدة قدم خدمات مثل
غير ممكن أقسم لك أنه كذلك
جعلها حبي حبيبي